hello everyone I want to start by uh you
know personally and on behalf of the
Lakers family offering condolences -
offering condolences to Vanessa Bryant
and the entire Bryant family on the loss
of Kobe and Gianna we are all deeply
deeply saddened by this unthinkable
tragedy and thoughts and prayers are
with you I also want to offer
condolences to the families of the other
victims that were lost in this tragedy
thoughts and prayers are with you as
well and with that I'll open up for
questions hotel emotional has this been
for you in your family at home and your
Laker family here extremely emotional on
both fronts you know it's been something
that has touched my family being the
father of daughters it's been very
emotional and you know something that it
brings us together and then as well as
the Lakers family you know I'm around
you know I'm around the people and they
were closest to Kobe you know throughout
his time here and you know it's been a
just a deeply saddening time for all of
us
you know for me I just wanted to make
sure everybody knew and you know I some
of them had had heard you know I've seen
the reports some had not so it's just a
daunting task of just grabbing each guy
one-on-one and letting them know you
know this team can be ready together how
do you card against it breaking you
apart I don't think you could break us
apart in any way yeah I mean it's just a
feel thing you know you observe those
around you you observe your own feelings
and emotions and you know you proceed at
the right pace at the right time Frank
is it bring pop up playing this season
for Colby that's the other thing you
know we want to we want to represent
what Colby was about you know more than
anything we've always always wanted to
make him proud and you know that's not
gonna be any different here what did you
guys get done yesterday and breathing
we uh we did some things that that we
felt would be therapy therapeutically
beneficial we got into gym for some some
team shooting work no real practice
working on anything in particular I one
of our guys to come in mentally free but
to get a sweat touch the ball to be
around each other and then and then we
had a lunch you know where we all you
know just spend time together and grieve
together if you had a chance what would
you tell Kobe Bryant
you know I'm not ready to go there you
know I really not you know some
questions I'm not going it's just not
gonna be able to answer right now
favorite Kobe story no I'm not ready to
go there either okay well it's just
strengthened what we've felt all year
about our current group which is uh you
know we've become a family in a very
short time and you know it's something
you talk about in the NBA with your
teams but this group in particular has
really grown to love each other very
rapidly and you know we understand the
importance of the opportunity we have
this year and you know this has just
brought us closer together knowing how
much he loved his daughters and
supported women's sports I mean it's
just you connect with that you know and
you feel it you know because it's it's
what your life is about him him being a
father two daughters and being involved
in their sports was you know the most
enjoyable thing you know in his life you
know from my observations and it's the
most enjoyable thing in my life I love
being the coach of the Lakers but it
doesn't come close to comparing to my
family time and you know so it's very
relatable
tackle the task of leading this group
really the same way they have throughout
the year you know you know we've
collaborated with em on you know what
the next few days would look like you
know they've been vocal in terms of you
know just helping the help in the group
manage their emotions and get through
this Frank
the decision process is uh you guys can
speak when you're ready and not before
you've been in the gym for twenty years
most of Kobe's career just wondered what
impact you saw on the other players that
you've coached for against uh trying to
prepare a scouting report you know to
deal with him all that stuff well he was
the the most feared man in the league
for an entire generation and you know
the influence is profound league-wide
basketball community wide worldwide
Lakers family right we just say it's
fair to say in addition to wanting to
win it for yourselves you guys now want
to win the championship for Kobe we want
we want to want to represent what he
stood for you know that's that's the
most important thing for us we want to
represent what he stood for
I think it's therapeutic
something like help with the process of
us moving forward